Ngày bị bày thống một các cuộc biểu tình phản đối các quan tự thế dí chủ và hải quan Mỹ A.C.
Thì tục dễn xa để thành phố Minapolis, bằng Minnesu Tà và có chíu hưởng phức tạm hơn.
Theo yên anh kinh nhật, hàng chục người đến yóm lửa bình ngoài gọi nhạm đứa
Shortheary We Pro, Hoa Thổ hiểu phản đối A.C. và kinh sát, lực lượng trưng năng có mặt để giập lửa
sống người biểu tình lại nhóm lửa và tôn hành trở lại so khi lực lượng trưng năng dưới đi.
Lần sau cũng trong A.C. ra tăng tự tối như mạng tham một khi một người đa nóng nhập cư tốt với Nysu La bị bắn vào chân.
Chúng lúc tìm cách bảo chốn khảo sẽ ổ tổ, sau một cuộc bộ sán của các đặc bộ.
Nguyên này sau đó đúng được vào bình biển với phía thương không đe dọa tự tính mạch.
Hoa ra, hành người khác cũng bị bắt sửa.
Chứ đón người một bày thống một cuộc bằng bày tuổi tây nơi về đi, hồ gứt, bị mua đặc buối A.C.
Bánh chế tại Minapolis Police, chương nội cho là giống biểu tình phản đối A.C.